pour delà des pyramides au delà de ce
que vous pensez savoir découvrez
l'egypte a connu c'est comme recrée
ensemble un puzzle en trois dimensions
pour la première fois marcher sur les
lieux que seuls les pharaons ont foulé
pour les anciens c'est le sublime du
sublime un voyage où aucune caméra de
télévision n'avait été autorisée à
filmer jusqu'à aujourd'hui on dirait
presque que l'artiste a reposé son
pinceau et quitter le templière
seulement maintenant peter woodward va
vous faire découvrir la terre d'égypte
l'egypte
au delà des pyramides
[Musique]
le caire l'une des plus belles villes du
monde avec ses 16 millions d'habitants
elle se trouve à cheval sur le nil
pas très loin de l'ancienne capitale
memphis depuis plus de 5000 ans soit
depuis l'époque des pharaons
l'egypte est un pays spirituelle à la
fois intense
l'egypte est devenue de différentes
manières un carrefour pour certaines des
religions prédominante du monde ici au
caire la plus grande métropole musulmane
du monde
il suffit d'écouter pour s'en rappeler
la cacophonie de la vie moderne et
ponctué cinq fois par jour par l'appel à
la prière
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
le caire compte des centaines de
mosquées de tous âges et de toutes
dimensions la grande mosquée du sultan
hassan a été construite au cours du 14e
siècle
c'est la manifestation extraordinaire
d'une inspiration spirituel considérable
cependant le judaïsme et le
christianisme ont également trouvé fort
ses motivations dans cette ville
ces religions ici aussi leurs lieux de
culte la synagogue benezra a été
construite au 9e siècle
la légende veut que ce soit à cet
endroit que la fille du pharaon et
recueillie moïse à leur bébé avant que
le nil ne l'emportent
il y a également de nombreuses églises
au caire la plupart sont copte une secte
qui formaient l'une des premières
branches du christianisme
j'ai visité l'église suspendu datant du
ivème siècle où l'on peut se rendre
compte des liens spirituels intacte qui
existe avec l'histoire ancienne de
l'egypte si l'on cherchait les images et
les sons de l'ancienne égypte
aujourd'hui c'est ici dans l'église
copte qu on les trouverait
les mots de ces brière et ces chants
sont les indices subtils que l'on
possède concernant la langue parlée par
les anciens égyptiens et la foi fervente
de cet office est un lien direct avec la
profonde spiritualité de l'egypte des
pharaons
[Musique]
les chants l'encens et les hiéroglyphes
encore utilisé dans la langue coptes
remonte à une religion encore plus
ancien qui a commencé ici il ya plus de
50 siècles
aujourd'hui les lieux de culte du caire
représente un lien tangible avec cette
époque lointaine
une époque à laquelle deux magnifiques
temples fournissent le fondement
spirituel de l'une des premières grandes
civilisations de l'humanité le pouvoir
des anciens pharaons trouve ses origines
dans une hiérarchie complexe de dieux et
de déesses
c'est une religion qui attache beaucoup
d'importance aux rituels et cérémonie au
centre de cette religion se trouve le
temple lieu merveilleux et mystérieux
les temples étaient des points de
contact entre l'humain et le divin
fondamentalement les égyptiens concevait
le temple comme étant avant tout la
demeure des dieux
dès lors l'objet essentiel du rituel au
temple était de prendre soin des dieux
et de les nourrir
[Musique]
la seconde fonction du temple et de
représenter physiquement la conception
égyptienne de la création
[Musique]
les égyptiens croyait que le monde avait
commencé comme un marais primordial
un lieu de chaos et de confusion mais de
se marrer les dieux ont sorti un
monticule ou un îlot de sûreté qui est
devenu l'egypte afin de symboliser ce
monticule créateurs les temples sont
toujours construits avec une section
légèrement surélevé en leur milieu
le tertre du temple rappelle aux
égyptiens que le chaos primordial pour y
revenir si les dieux n'étaient pas
contents
pendant plus de trois mille ans la peur
du chaos et le désir d'ordre ont été au
coeur des croyances religieuses de la
civilisation égyptienne
les égyptiens connaissent très
clairement la limite entre les deux le
désert représente le chaos et l'absence
de vie laval est alimentée par le nil
représente la sécurité le temple est
l'institution qui a assuré la sécurité
de l'egypte
le dieu assurer la stabilité il empêcher
le chaos
vous savez qu'au coeur du temple le dieu
est là veillant sur vous et que le
pharaon va faire à ce dieu les offrandes
appropriée en votre nom
ce que le monde va continuer à
fonctionner correctement le nil va se
gonfler il y aura des crues la
nourriture va pousser
c'est un processus mutuelle qui continue
à travers les âges
[Musique]
les temples évolue rapidement pour
devenir davantage qu'une demeure pour
les dieux ils deviennent le centre de
toute vie dans la communauté
quand on pense aux temples de l'egypte
ancienne
on pense en fait à quelque chose de
beaucoup plus grand qu'un lieu de culte
c'est un lieu religieux économiques
quelque chose qui ressemble à un grand
monastère européen du moyen-âge qui
possède ses propres terres il a ses
troupeaux il s'agit d'institutions
économiques importantes au sein de la
structure de l'egypte
les premiers temples remonte aux
origines de la civilisation égyptienne
soit plus de 4000 ans avant l'ère
chrétienne
ces premiers lieux sacrés se limite sans
doute à des murs fait de nattes de
roseaux ou de peaux de bêtes les temples
plus récents sont construits en briques
de terre
étonnamment certaines de ces structures
ont survécu
[Musique]
le temple immense de l'un des premiers
pharaons cas sec et mouillé à abidos
date de plus de 5000 ans cependant les
grands murs de cas sec et mouillé sont
une exception
la plupart de ses anciens temples ont
disparu depuis longtemps sous l'effet de
l'érosion inexorable du vent du désert
ceci est une brique en terre de la boue
tiré du nil mélangé avec de la paille
est cuite sous le soleil égyptien tous
les bâtiments anciens étaient construits
avec de telle brique depuis le palais du
pharo jusqu'à la mesure du paysan dans
des conditions sèches idéal elles
peuvent durer mille ans comme dans le
temple de caciques et mouiller à abidos
mais la majeure partie de l'egypte
habitable était proche du nil et sans
cesse l'objet d'inondations après
plusieurs siècles ce matériau se dissout
et repart dans le nil et les égyptiens
le savez c'était acceptable pour les
maisons d'habitation des vivants après
tout la vie n'est qu'une phase
temporaire sans revanche les tombes des
morts et les tempes des dieux devaient
eux pouvoir durer les égyptiens étaient
sur le point de devenir les plus grands
experts au monde d'un nouveau matériau
la pierre avec celle ci ils ont créé
certains des plus extraordinaires
monument de l'histoire des hommes
[Musique]
nous avons découvert les débuts de la
construction de temples en egypte nous
en voyons maintenant l'apogée magnifique
voici le temple de karnak après les
pyramides
c'est la réalisation architecturale la
plus spectaculaire dans l'histoire de
l'egypte ancienne
c'est le plus grand temple jamais
construit il s'étend sur une surface
dépassant 30 hectares un espace
suffisamment vaste pour y faire tenir la
cathédrale de notre dame et le quartier
qui l'entourent
le temple de karnak se tient sur la rive
est du nil là où se trouvait jadis
thèbes la capitale du sud de l'egypte
ancienne la capitale actuelle et la
ville de louxor située à environ 720 km
du caire plusieurs pharaons se sont
succédé sur deux siècles pour construire
et agrandir ce temple imposant près de
1200 ans avant l'ère chrétienne
cet ensemble impressionnant de portes et
de salles remplies de colonne a été bâti
pour honorer une seule divinité amont le
roi des dieux
c'est un dieu très important le dieu le
plus important en egypte du fait de
cette position celle de roi des dieux
reçoit les faveurs du pharaon et toutes
les grandes salles qui sont ici les
pylônes tout est construit pour lui avec
son épouse mouthe la déesse de la
maternité à mon règne sur la capitale
thèbes plus que tout autre délit tc
hamon qui sert à légitimer et à
renouveler sans cesse l'autorité des
pharaons dans les recoins les plus
sombres les plus silencieux de carnac le
dieu amon réside sous la forme d'une
statue
curieusement la statue n'a rien de
colossales c'est au contraire une
représentation de dimensions modestes
qui peut être facilement transporté lors
de festivités les longs murs de carnac
est effet d'énormes blocs de grès les
bâtisseurs se sont heurtés à d'immenses
difficultés de construction
oubliez pas qu il n'est pas question de
grues ou même de simples pas lent pour
soulever ces blocs de pierre et les
mettre en place
à la place les maçons de l'egypte
ancienne se servent de terre ici on peut
voir les vestiges d'une gigantesque
europe le long de laquelle on tirait les
blocs de pierre jusqu'à leur place dans
cet énorme pylônes ou ce portail lorsque
chaque niveau de pierre était terminée
ont réhaussé la rampe lorsque le dernier
mur et est enfin terminée on démolit
c'est la rendent progressivement et
chaque niveau de pierre et est ornée de
sculptures et de peintures en descendant
la grande salle hypostyle et le choeur
de carnac commencer par le pharaon
amenhotep iii au 14e siècle avant
jésus-christ la salle contient cent
trente et une colonne qui soutenait
jadis le toit à plus de 24 mètres au
dessus du sol du temple
[Musique]
la lumière entrée au travers de fenêtres
percée dans le toit est inondé le
spectaculaire couloir central mais les
couloirs latéraux qui sont aujourd'hui
sous le soleil serait restée dans le
noir le plus complet 15 obélisque dédié
au roi soleil ray ont été érigés dans
tout le temple il a fallu toute la
technique d'ingénierie des égyptiens
pour sculpter les colonnes massive les
traîner le long de rampes en terre et
ensuite les installer avec précaution la
pointe des obélisques était jadis
recouverte d'or de manière à saisir les
premiers rayons du soleil à l'aube et
les derniers au crépuscule la lumière
brillante reflétée par ces colonnes
honoré l'importance primordiale du
soleil pour le maintien de toute vie
c'est important de collection de
monuments de maçonnerie ne serait pas
l'oeuvre d'esclaves mais de citoyens
libres effectivement tous les égyptiens
sont censés être disponible à un moment
dans l'année pour travailler sur les
grands projets de construction du
pharaon ce serait l'équivalent du
service militaire
les ouvriers qui érige ces temples sont
des gens du peuple
les effectuent leur service de travail
et leur semaine de travail à carnac
c'est sans doute un impôt à payer 2 on
travaille sur la demeure du dieu c'est
un grand service rendu au roi et à amont
on assure la stabilité de la vie pour
l'éternité en construisant ici
bien que les égyptiens de la classe
ouvrière est construit ce temple ils
sont sans doute autorisés à entrer
seulement dans les cours extérieures
durant les festivités
léo l'intérieur sont réservées à l'élite
des prêtres car c'est là que les esprits
des dieux sont les plus présents chaque
pharaons se sent à son tour appelé à
proclamer sa dévotion à amont et par la
même occasion sa propre grandeur les
murs et colonnes du temple fonctionnent
comme des posters ou panneau d'affichage
où l'on peut graver exposer son
adoration du dieu au reste du monde
le docteur williams no name de
l'université de memphis étudie les
inscriptions du temple de karnak depuis
plus de 30 ans je suppose que mon
intérêt pour ce bâtiment a commencé par
une simple curiosité
enfin il est tellement bien conservé
c'est un peu bête de ne pas savoir quand
on chausse de son mystère pourquoi il a
été construit
ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce qu'il nous
apprend de la mentalité religieuse des
anciens égyptiens
cette manière sur de commencer à
comprendre l'importance d'un bâtiment
tel que celui ci est de comprendre ce
qui est sculptée sur les murs la simple
photographie des inscriptions est
délicate
au cours de plusieurs centaines d'années
est une succession de pharaon des
sculptures ont été réalisés par dessus
les sculptures plus ancienne mais en m
effectué tous ses tracés avec précaution
de manière à ce que toutes les couches
puisse être minutieusement étudiées
en effet ces images ne sont parfois pas
ce qu'elle paraît au premier abord
l'un des éléments que l'on trouve sans
cesse souligné dans ce temple l
équilibre entre la façon dont les choses
sont et devrait être est ce qui se passe
réellement dans le temple je pense que
vous pouvez en voir une très bonne
illustration parisse y est vous avez cet
oiseau qui est un hiéroglyphe pour le
peuple d'égypte vous remarquerez qu'il
est placé dans un panier ce qui est un
autre hiéroglyphes signifiant tout et
l'oiseau a des bras qui pousse n'est pas
à cause d'une mutation génétique mais
parce qu'il s'agit d'un morceau d'un
autre héros glyphes à la vue de ses bras
tendus des égyptiens penserez
immédiatement au mot signifiant adoré
au cas où vous n'auriez pas saisi les
toiles l'étoile à cinq branches est un
autre héros glyphes égyptiens qui
signifie en fait adorer donc vous
obtenez tout le monde
adorant le roi des détails tels que
celui ci ont suggéré qu'il ne s'agissait
pas seulement d'un symbole pour les
hommes adorent ans le roi dieu c'est
également un logo pour une société
fondamentalement il est très après tout
il ne faut pas oublier qu'en egypte
seuls un ou deux pourcent de l'élite
savent lire et écrire
alors pour tous les autres quelque chose
de ce genre voudrait dire quand vous
voyez cela sur une colonne vous avez le
droit de vous tenir là un oiseau qui
sert en réalité à contrôler la foule
n'est que l'une des surprises qui vous
attendent ici si vous savez où et
comment chercher aujourd'hui le visiteur
moyen sera peut être étonné d'apprendre
que tout cet assortiment terne de pierre
sculptée était jadis peint de couleurs
sublimes les quelques sections de
décoration pinte qui existent encore
nous donne un aperçu extrêmement en
temps du passé fabuleux de carnac les
efforts de conservation sont impérieux
car comme vous pouvez le constater le
mur est en train de s'effriter les
anneaux comportant des inscriptions de
noms que vous pouvez voir au dessus de
moi étaient intactes quand nous les
avons photographié en 1992 ils ont
maintenant pratiquement disparu alors
chaque fois que j'en ai assez de ce que
je suis en train de faire je reviens ici
pour me rappeler que nous sommes dans
une course contre la montre et combien
il est important de documenter tout ceci
avant qu'il ne disparaisse complètement
malheureusement la nappe phréatique
égyptienne ne cesse de remonter depuis
la construction du grand barrage
d'assouan en 1969
agissant comme une éponge la nature
poreuse de ces pierres anciennes attire
maintenant ses taux et les selles nocifs
qu'elles transportent
néanmoins d'autres égyptologue continue
de s'évertuer à révéler davantage de
secrets que recèlent encore ses murs
merveilleux
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur du temple de karnak
le saint des saints où la statue du
grand dieu amon était conservée le toit
est désormais absents mais il y a trois
mille cinq cents ans cet endroit aurait
été très sombre et très calmes seuls les
prêtres les plus privilégiés étant
autorisés à y entrer
chaque matin l'un d'entre eux ouvrez les
portes de la chasse du dieu lui même
dont la statue se tenait ici ensuite on
l'avait la statue on lui donner son bain
matinal et on l'enduit z huiles
précieuses
après quoi on l'habillait de vêtements
les plus délicats on lui laissait des
offrandes ici des fleurs ou des huiles
peut-être et sur cette grande table on
disposait de la nourriture devant le
dieu de manière à ce qu'ils puissent se
restaurer durant la journée
bien entendu le dieu ne prenait que
l'essence de la nourriture
après un laps de temps jugé approprié ce
sont les prêtres qui consommaient la
nourriture elle même enfin il faisait
brûler de l'encens et ensuite on
laissait le dieu profité de sa journée
en paix
[Musique]
à carnac les grands prêtres sont
désignés par le pharaon les autres
prêtres sont des laïcs issus de familles
importantes
cependant il y à de nombreux emplois au
temple qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir
avec ses fonctions religieuses les
temples n'était pas juste le domaine de
la royauté et des prêtres des centaines
d'hommes du peuple étaient nécessaires
au fonctionnement quotidien de ces
immenses centres religieux des fermiers
des charpentiers des maçons des
forgerons des potiers et beaucoup
d'autres étaient employés par les
temples qui comptait sur eux pour leurs
besoins physiques aussi bien que
spirituelle charles 26 plein est en ce
moment en train de conduire les fouilles
sur le site d'un ancien atelier qui
était autrefois au service du temple de
karnak à un moment au cours de
l'histoire du temple de karnak
ceci était une fabrique c'était
l'endroit où il fabriquait les statuts
c'était l'endroit où il fabriquait les
bijoux il traitait le cuivre à cet
endroit particulier on trouve beaucoup
d' indices contradictoires sur ce qui se
passe j'ai des endroits où il ya des
concentrations de terre riche en
particules métalliques que l'on n'a pas
encore analysé mais qui ressemble fort à
quelque chose dont on ne prononce pas le
nom en égyptologie c'est le mot qui
commence par un os c'est terrible ce mot
c'est lors les archéologues ont horreur
de trouver de l'or parce que c'est
seulement un problème et ça nous apprend
jamais rien l'attrait séculaire de l'or
à semer la confusion dans plus d'un site
de fouilles pour d archéologie sérieux
sa présence ne fait que les distraire de
la poursuite de découverte la plus
importante
il y à toute une série de bassins l'un
au dessus de l'autre ils descendent sur
plus d'un mètre vingt ils mettaient de
les toffes au fond et attendait que des
dépôts se forment les dépôts étaient
éliminés par filtrage il rajouter de
l'eau jour après jour peut-être essayer
tilde extraire de l'or c'est sans doute
la théorie la plus plausible pour cette
semaine c'est une question à laquelle je
n'ai pas encore trouvé de réponse
mais c'est sa l'archéologie
toutes les facettes de la vie
quotidienne des égyptiens dépendent de
la poterie
on trouve partout des jarres des
bouteilles les cuvettes des bols des
dépôts on pourrait penser que tout les
poteries sont déterrés et conservait
cependant plus de 3000 ans d'histoire
ont contribué à les réduire en morceaux
cet endroit est presque entièrement
jonché littéralement 2 millions de
tessons de poterie voici un tesson que
je qualifie habituellement 2 à bâle à un
terme arabe qui signifie ordures c'est
un morceau d'une poterie qui ne possède
aucun élément caractéristique
susceptible de me fournir des
renseignements la concernant alors on le
jette alors que passent les siècles le
culte du grand dieu amon s'amenuisent la
civilisation égyptienne subi l'assaut
d'autres cultures
le temple de karnak et finalement fermé
par les romains au 4e siècle quand les
européens aperçoivent enfin carnac au
xviiie siècle
ces grandes salles sont remplis de sable
des feux de camp au narcisse et beaux
murs peints et seuls des paysans et
leurs ânes examine les inscriptions
sacré qui était à l'origine destiné aux
dieux
mais alors que commence le 20e siècle
carnac est à nouveau remplis d'énergie
et de passion
sauf qu'il s'agit désormais de la
passion de la découverte et de la
restauration
aujourd'hui personne ne vit plus à
carnac on a déblayé le sable pour
découvrir ceux ci des centaines de blocs
de pierres à l'issue d'investigations
longue et précise françois larcher et
son équipe française ont réussi
l'impossible
à partir de ces blocs pris au hasard ils
sont parvenus à reconstruire un bâtiment
entier ils ont recréé la chapelle rouge
de la reine hatchepsout
[Musique]
hatshepsout est l'une des rares
souveraine que l'egypte a connu en 1487
avant jésus-christ soit quatre ans avant
la fin de son règne
cette reine dynamique a fait construire
un petit temple juste en dehors de
carnac réalisa en quartzite rouge
il devient rapidement connu sous le nom
de chapelle rouge elle n'est utilisé que
pendant quelques années pour des raisons
que l'on ne comprend pas encore très
bien le beau fils et successeur de
hatshepsout touthmôsis iii fait démolir
la chapelle rouge le temps que les
égyptologues la découvre plus de 3000
ans plus tard les seuls vestiges
visibles se composait de quelques blocs
de pierre de grande dimension françois
larcher est fasciné par ces blocs
quand je suis arrivé à carnac en 1987
j'ai vu les blocs de la chapelle rouge
et j'ai demandé des renseignements à ce
sujet et la plupart de mes collègues me
disait qu'il était impossible de
reconstruire la chapelle parce que trop
de blocs et des manquants
larcher et son équipe entreprennent
l'impossible heureusement certaines des
pires qui formaient autrefois les murs
de la chapelle rouges avaient fait
l'objet de gravure racontant une
histoire
malheureusement la plupart de ces
pierres avaient été réutilisés dans
d'autres parties de carnac
le défi consistait à les retrouver et à
les réassembler la première opération
effectuée pour cette étude consistait à
prendre environ deux mille photos des
côtés de ces blocs de pierre
fès of death blocks les photos des blocs
de la chapelle servent à l'archet de
patron à partir duquel il peut
travailler c'est comme assembler les
pièces d'un puzzle en trois dimensions
vous n'avez pas la boîte dont vous
n'avez pas la photo et il manque la
moitié des pièces la chapelle rouges
avaient été conçus pour contenir un
petit bateau le bateau servait à
transporter le dieu amon lors de
l'importante fait de hope est qu'ils
avaient lieu chaque année au début des
inondations au cours de la procession le
bateau de hamon était porté hors de
carnac et et défilé devant les gens du
peuple lors d'un parcours d'une journée
pour aller rencontrer le roi
au cours de cette rencontre le roi
rendait hommage au dieu est le dieu
renouveler le droit du pharaon de renier
pour une autre année des scènes de ce
voyage était dépeindre sur des blocs
numérotés qui faisait partie des murs de
la chapelle
une fois que larcher a découvert
certains de ces blocs
il a la clé culé permettra de comprendre
l'ordre de chaque rangée de pierre 6,5
blog dans une rangée ont une longueur
individuelle d'environ 75 cm et les
logiques que le bloc manquant dans la
série sera de la même longueur
les scènes avec la chasse est celle avec
les prêtres portant la barque sont de la
même longueur il était relativement
facile d'additionner ses longueurs aux
parties manquantes pour reconstruire une
partie du troisième niveau
une fois que
puzzle était finalement assemblée sur le
papier il a fallu seulement neuf mois
pour reconstruire la partie principale
de la chapelle rouge
malheureusement certains des blocs n'ont
jamais été retrouvés dans ses murs le
plâtre lice remplit l'espace laissé vide
par des blocs manquants il sera
finalement pas de la couleur des pierres
original le travail continue sur la
chapelle rouge alors que certaines des
pièces manquantes sont recréés à la main
cependant pour la première fois depuis
le nouvel empire
on peut admirer la magnifique chasse de
hatshepsout et s'étonner de tout ce que
nous ne connaissions pas je trouve qu'il
est fascinant d'essayer d'imaginer les
scènes mystérieuses et dramatiques qui
se déroulent et jadis dans cette
merveilleuse petite chapelle
[Musique]
le seul jour de l'année où l'égyptien
moyen avait en fait l'opportunité de
voir le dieu amour et était la fête de
hope est le dieu été retiré de son
sanctuaire est amenée ici à la chapelle
rouge à l'intérieur
à cet endroit précis se trouvait un
petit bateau ou une barque qui
transporterait le dieu au cours de son
voyage il était placé dans la barque et
des prêtres à la tête rasée vêtues de
robes de cérémonie en peau de léopard
soulevé la barque sacré sur leurs
épaules et l'a transporté hors du temple
de karnak jusqu à louxor situés à plus
d'un kilomètre et demi de là le long de
l'avenue des sphinx
[Musique]
les trompettes retentissant la proche de
la procession du dieu les soldats dans
des chars couverts de plumes fond lahaye
le long du parcours les spectateurs
chantent et applaudissent tandis que les
musiciens passent les cordes de leurs
luttes et bat du tambour et des cymbales
des danseurs oscille sur ces rythmes des
acrobates saute en l'air et par tout le
peuple applaudit à la vue du dieu
d'honneur de vie
[Applaudissements]
les nombreux vestiges du temple de
karnak subsistent pour nous donner un
merveilleux aperçu de ce à quoi
ressemblait cet endroit il ya 3500
néanmoins les effets du temps du vent
d'un tremblement de terre et même du
vandalisme ont été dévastateurs il faut
nous tourner vers d'autres temples pour
pouvoir apprécier le caractère mystique
de l' architecture des temples égyptiens
ainsi que la beauté délicate de leur
décoration l'un des plus imposants de
ces temples a été construit pendant la
période de prospérité de carnac
il a été créé par le pharaon sethi 1er
le père de ramsès le grand pour honorer
osiris le dieu des enfers
[Musique]
je voulais voir ce temple très spéciale
alors j'ai descendu le nil pendant
quelques heures de carnac jusqu'à la
ville ancienne de à bidos
[Musique]
c'est vendredi le jour saint de la
semaine dans l'égypte actuelle on peut
entendre le muezzin appelant les fidèles
à la prière ce qui subsiste de l'egypte
ancienne c'est sa religion des tombes
des temples des monuments pour les
égyptiens de l'époque voilà ce que
l'égypte représenter une religion
vivante qui a impliqué directement le
peuple tout entier une religion qui a
perduré
connaissant très peu de changements
pendant trois mille ans nous avons vu
les splendeurs de carnac cependant afin
de les apprécier réellement et de
comprendre le pouvoir de l' influence de
ces temples de nouvel empire
il faut venir ici à abidos ce temple
extraordinaire bâti par ses 10 premiers
pour le dieu osiris peu de touristes
viennent jusqu'ici certaines parties de
ce temple n'ont même jamais été filmées
notre guide et mathieu adams de
l'université de pennsylvanie
matthew parlez-nous de cet endroit
étonnant où nous trouvons nous eh bien
nous nous trouvons dans la première
salle hypostyle du temple de ses dix
premiers à abidos les nous venons
d'entrer quittant le monde ensoleillé
des vivants de l'egypte ancienne et nous
nous introduisons lentement dans le
monde un peu plus sombre du divin 7e'
premier est à l'origine de la
construction de ce top lequel était son
attention et bien depuis au moins le
début du moyen empire aux alentours de
2000 avant jésus-christ à bidos était
considéré comme le principal lieu de
culte du dieu osiris le souverain du
pays des maures les égyptiens croyez
qu'il avait été enterré ici que sa tombe
se trouve est ici dans le désert et
c'est yves voulait s'associer au culte
de osiris en bâtissant ce temple
magnifique
c'est ce qu'il a réussi à faire
[Musique]
je crois que c'est sans doute le style
de sculptures le plus délicat jamais
réalisée en egypte
et bien ici on voit le roi c'est y qui
tient un brûleur à on sent ici on peut
voir la flamme de l'encens en train de
brûler qui monte il fait offrande de
cela une représentation du dieu osiris
qui est accompagné de plusieurs autres
des hits et on voit osiris trônant sur
une estrade à l'intérieur d'une chasse
qui est seulement indiqué par la
présence de lignes fines encerclant la
représentation où cette chasse
pouvait-elle se trouvait le temple
comporter un certain nombre de chapelle
consacrée à différentes des hits et
l'une d'entre elles était consacrée à
osiris et cette représentation où
l'image de ce qu'ils étaient
représentées devait se trouver dans la
chapelle est-ce qu'on peut aller voir
voici la chapelle d'osiris et on le voit
sous différentes apparences ici avec le
roi faisant offrande dansant et de
libations est en adoration devant
l'image du dieu
cela donne vraiment une idée de ce à
quoi ressemble et les décorations
originales de la plupart des temples
égyptiens
elle devait être dense et ont
incroyablement vibrant et vif
on dirait presque que l'artiste a reposé
son pinceau et quitter le templière
seulement les images que l'on boit this
in sont d'une grande assistance pour
comprendre la nature des rituels ayant
lieu au temple
cependant le temple c'est inné pas
uniquement important pour permettre aux
égyptiens de comprendre les dieux les
cultes et les rituels du temple il revêt
également une importance particulière
dans l'histoire de l'egypte
[Rires]
[Musique]
les murs de cette pièce nous apporte
l'un des plus importants documents
historiques datant de l'egypte ancienne
quelque chose qui a été d'une valeur
immense pour permettre aux égyptiens de
comprendre la chronologie de l'histoire
égyptienne
il s'agit de la liste des noms des rois
de l'egypte ancienne
[Musique]
la liste commence au début avec le nom
du roi ménès ici appelé men et qui était
le fondateur légendaire de l'egypte
ancienne
et ça continue en passant par la plupart
des souverains de l'egypte ancienne
jusqu'à c'est ici qui a construit ce
temple
c'est donc une période considérable de
l'histoire qui se trouve ici
absolument cela représente près de 2000
ans de l'histoire égyptienne
il s'agit seulement d'une liste et cela
toute son importance que nous
apprend-elle d'autres eh bien elle nous
apprend que les égyptiens étaient
conscients de la grande profondeur de
leur histoire il aurait été beaucoup
plus difficile pour l'égyptologie
d'établir les grandes dates de
l'histoire égyptienne ancien sans ces
documents et d'autres documents
similaires
bien que cet eee premier soit le dernier
nom sur la liste
il est mort avant que le temple ne soit
achevé c'est son fils ramsès il a fait
terminé cependant l'histoire le
considérera toujours comme le cadeau
éternelle de cetti un magnifique
monument dédié à la spiritualité
profonde et à la grandeur artistique de
l'egypte ancienne
[Musique]
en 1570 avant jésus-christ soit un
millier d'années après la construction
des grandes pyramides une nouvelle
période de l'histoire égyptienne
commence on l'appelle le nouvel empire
les grands pharaons de cette époque tels
que ramsès le fils de ses dix premiers
possèdent un pouvoir et un prestige
énorme
ils vont développer et achever une
catégorie de temples complètement
différente
nous sommes en train de traverser le nil
à l'endroit où se situait l'ancienne
ville sainte de thèbes juste un peu plus
bas sur cette rive se trouve la ville de
louxor et le temple de karnak
mais c'est vers l'autre rive que se sont
tournés les pharaons pour créer un
nouveau genre de temple ceux ci
n'étaient pas consacré à un dieu en
particulier comme hamon à carnac
l'osiris à abidos il s'agit plutôt de
temple mortuaire consacré à l'honneur
d'un dieu vivant le pharaon lui même
[Musique]
les pharaons ont toujours nécessité un
lieu où même après la mort il pourrait
recevoir des louanges et des offrandes
un endroit adapté ou leur mémoire
pourrait être vénéré quotidiennement
il ne suffit pas que le record soit
préservé il faut également maintenir la
mémoire glorieuse du roi défunt afin
qu'il conserve sa propre place dans
l'éternité
[Musique]
des espaces appropriés pour ces
activités sont incorporées dans la
conception des pyramides néanmoins
l'existence de pilleurs de tombes oblige
les pharaons à rechercher des tombes
plus petites plus sûr dans la vallée des
rois et crée le besoin de structures
commémorative spéciale le résultat est
le temple mortuaire et ramsès 2 fait
construire l'un des plus élégants de ces
temples sur l'autre rive du fleuve en
face de carnac le temple spectaculaire
qu'il crée connu sous le nom de drames
et ses hommes c'est un monument
approprié pour le pharaon que l'histoire
connaît comme ramsès legrand son
emplacement sur la rive ouest du nil à
thèbes est en réalité un complexe
immense de cimetières couvrant plusieurs
dizaines de kilomètres carrés les grand
temple mortuaire bâti par les pharaons
sont tous très près les uns des autres
juste en contrebas du ram et ses hommes
se trouvent le médine est à bout le
temple resplendissant construit par
ramsès iii est pas très loin de là se
tient un autre grand hommage au pouvoir
et à l'ego nous sommes en route pour
aller visiter le plus spectaculaire des
temple mortuaire un temple construit
pour honorer l'un des plus grands
pharaons d'égypte à pharaon qui était
non pas un droit mais une reine
son nom aurait hatshepsout la même
rennes qui avait fait bâtir la chapelle
rouge à carnac
à l'origine elle n'est pas tant une
reine que la femme d'un roi de tout
moses deux pour être plus précis
cependant à la mort de son époux le
titre de roi est passé à un garçon le
beau-fils de hatshepsout touthmôsis iii
le garçon est trop jeune pour régner
aussi hatshepsout devient régente en
charge du pays jusqu'à la majorité du
jeune roi
mais cette femme remarquable a beaucoup
d'assurance ainsi que de l'ambition au
cours de la deuxième année du règne de
son beau-fils hatshepsout se fait
proclamer roi
[Musique]
elle décrète qu'elle sera dorénavant
décrite non pas comme une femme est
comme un homme jusqu'à la fausse barbe
traditionnelle du pharaon le règne de
hatchet sauter paisible et l'egypte
prospère les expéditions de commerce
sont envoyés vers des terres lointaines
et la reine élaborent des projets de
constructions gigantesques aucun n'est
plus ambitieux que sa construction d'un
temple pour se commémorer elle même près
de 1500 ans avant l'ère chrétienne la
reine hatchepsout commence la
construction d'un temple pour rendre
hommage à son règne
elle a choisi cet emplacement
spectaculaire un amphithéâtre naturel en
pierre des escarpements de plus de 300 m
aujourd'hui il porte le nom de deir
el-bahari mais pour les anciens c'était
le sublime des sublimes
l'architecte de la chip soude s'appelle
sonné min certains pensent qu'ils sont
également à man elle lui demande de
concevoir un temple qui émerveillera les
générations à venir et il a réussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aucun constructeur de l'egypte ancienne
ne possède un meilleur sens du
dramatique que celle mount trois
terrasses parfaitement proportionné
s'élève du sol de la vallée et semble se
fondre dans les imposantes falaises qui
entoure le temple
[Musique]
des rampes soigneusement proportionnée
relie ce niveau il y a des statuts de la
reine partout et dans les tons doux du
désert de l'aube au crépuscule
les pierres du temple dégage une lueur
magique proclamant pour l'éternité la
grandeur et le caractère sacré de la
reine hatchepsout cependant la renommée
peut s'avérer éphémère le contrôle par
hatshepsout de ce merveilleux temple ne
va pas durer
[Musique]
le travail sur ce chef-d'oeuvre
architectural commence au cours de la
septième année du règne de hachette
soute et continue pendant 15 ans ce
temple est construit en son honneur
alors que son image est omniprésente
hatshepsout représenté en pharaon
hatshepsout en osiris le dieu alors que
son temple est toujours debout 3500 ans
plus tard la plupart des représentations
de la grande reine elle même ont été
détruites peu après sa mort
tout mosys 3 devient pharaons d'égypte
en 1483 avant jésus-christ il est
convaincu que sa belle mère n'aurait
jamais dû devenir pharaons
alors quand il arrive à la fin de son
règne il fait tout son possible pour
effacer toute l'image de la reine de son
propre temple mais ici c'est le temps le
plus grand ennemi
les occupants suivant poursuivre la
dégradation de ses sculptures et des
tremblements de terre font tomber muret
colonnes
[Musique]
arrive enfin le 20e siècle le superbe
temple de hatshepsout est dans un triste
état
les pavés se sont soulevés d'énormes
blocs de balustrades se sont effondrés
et des tas informe jonchent le sol en
1960 le gouvernement à financer un
projet de restauration travaillant avec
un groupe d'égyptologues polonais c'est
depuis un modèle de coopération
internationale
[Musique]
des éléments cruciaux du temple en
particulier le troisième niveau sont
éparpillés comme un énorme tas de cube
pour enfants la première tâche consiste
à analyser ces blocs et à les remettre à
leur place
l'un après l'autre on nous a accordé
l'accès à des sections du temple qui
sont fermés depuis plus de 30 ans c'est
une occasion rare d'observer le travail
de restauration de près des méthodes
anciennes sont employés pour recréer les
parties manquantes
la pierre est extraite des carrières
d'origine et apporter ici à deir
el-bahari les sculpteurs égyptien locaux
sont séparés des premiers artisans par
des milliers d'années néanmoins le soin
du détail et l'attention qu'ils
apportent à leur travail sont les mêmes
[Musique]
chacune de ces pierres et taillés à la
main mise en place à la main et au jugé
elles sont découpées pour prendre leur
place exacte et ensuite après celle ci
ils doivent remonter point par point le
long de cette grande rampe jusqu'au
troisième niveau et pour la première
fois depuis les temps anciens il sera
complet des centaines d'hommes
travaillent ici vous pouvez imaginer
dans les temps anciens des milliers
d'égyptiens travaillant côte à côte sous
la chaleur pour terminer ce monument
grandiose avec des fonds limités il n'y
a pas de machines modernes ici au lieu
de cela les ouvriers se servent de leur
dos pour porter les charges lourdes pour
se donner du rythme il entonne un chant
de travail en l'honneur du prophète
mahomet
[Applaudissements]
comme leurs ancêtres des siècles
auparavant il tire les blocs de pierre
le long de la rampe à la seule force de
leurs mains bien entendu ces hommes-là
travaille avec des roues les égyptiens
anciens eux peut être utilisée t-il des
traîneaux malgré tout c'est un travail
très dur
[Musique]
ces blocs de pierres calcaires sont
modernes mais ils sont coupés au même
tolérance que les pierres anciennes
chaque bloc est une réplique une
réplique exacte de ce qu'il y avait là
autrefois comme une pièce d'un puzzle
géant une section originale du temple
tout est mis en place sur la section
moderne correspondante
un morceau par morceau on reconstruit
deir el-bahari il est difficile
d'obtenir des financements pour ce
travail il a fallu plus de 30 ans
[Musique]
et on commence à en voir la fin et on
peut de nouveau voir la grande reine
d'égypte contemplant son merveilleux
temple
[Musique]
chaque année au cours d'une fête
spéciale le dieu amour et étaient amenés
ici sur le troisième niveau du temple de
hatshepsout la statue du dieu faisait
l'objet d'une procession qui l'emportait
en passant par cette cour
jusque dans une caverne creusé dans la
montagne là il se reposer pendant
quelques jours avant de commencer son
périple vers tous les temples de la rive
ouest
le public n'a jamais été autorisé dans
ce lieu mais bientôt le travail de
restauration sera terminée et les
visiteurs pourront se tenir ici sur la
terrasse sacrée et profiter de la vue
sur le nil que la reine hatchepsout
elle-même contempler jadis
[Musique]
comme toutes les structures anciennes de
l'egypte les grands temples subissent de
nombreuses menaces de la part du temps
et des éléments les peintures continuent
de disparaître les inscriptions
subissent l'érosion la montée de la
nappe phréatique menace les fondations
et représentent un risque pour les
sculptures importante
[Musique]
cependant grâce au travail de nombreuses
personnes dévouées ces grandes demeures
des esprits sont toujours là fort
heureusement elles proclament à
l'histoire
la relation unique des égyptiens avec
leur dieu
[Musique]
à la mémoire du docteur william murray m
dans le prochain épisode de l'egypte au
delà des pyramides
je continue à ne pas croire ceux qui
arrivent ensuite est un grand moment
d'archéologie moderne un grand pharaon
accueillent ces enfants dans le monde
des ténèbres
je n'ai jamais rien vu de tel dans ma
vie la découverte d'un tombeaux datant
de plusieurs millénaires
rien de tel n'a jamais été trouvé
auparavant
peter hall wardougou guide au travers de
cette découverte dans le prochain
épisode de l'egypte au delà des
pyramides
[Musique]